[Music]
all right does anyone miss sports
no yes it's about to be football season
and we don't know i don't care about no
sports
just kidding when does that start in
october uh september usually
yeah but like the draft happens or like
fantasy draft happens in august
i was actually feeling really bad for
the kids i just told her this like
two days ago because when i was thinking
about school right i think a lot of kids
are like
yeah no school zoom classes and i'm like
oh that's cool you know they get to take
a break or i know like for someone like
me
who has 80d i need to be in a classroom
but it's also kind of cool to just wear
pajamas and learn from home
and then it hit me where i was like but
what about the people that go to school
and they need school to succeed
and they're not in academia so for
example if you're trying to get into a
d1 school so you can get into the nba
or the nfl or whatever right like you
can't have
zoom practice or zoom football or zoom
basketball i'm like there's going to be
an entire
year or entire generation worth of
athletes that
aren't able to cross over because of
this too and i'm like [ __ ] what about
these kids cause some of these kids are
like
i'm gonna be in the nba since i'm five
they go to basketball camps they go to
like
they they go to like two or three
practices they plan city leagues all the
way until they're like 16 17 hopefully
to get scouted
and i'm like [ __ ] there's there's kids
that like
the the shutting down of the schools
affect them way more than someone that's
just trying to get like a 4.0 or
whatever yeah
or even the kids who have a shitty home
life and going to school was like their
only
respite yeah not like an alcoholic dad
or something
that beats you jesus i'm i'm really sad
for all the stoners who can't go
behind the bleachers and smoke weed
anymore because they're home all day
zoom
zoom out zoom this is the green screen
the bleachers
that's hilarious well a lot of people
seem to be
very very sad about not being able to
attend live sports events anymore so to
the point where
now fans are paying up to three hundred
dollars to get
cutouts of themselves to be sitting in
the seats
sitting in the seats at the dodger
stadium
where are they getting this money dude
aren't people out of work right now like
whoa
oh they're who they're giving the money
to no where are they getting this money
people that are getting unemployment
they're getting good money man 600 bucks
a week
some people are getting 900 a week whoa
a week
yeah a week i know people are like well
i'm making more than i made
yeah i ain't going back to work to me
when i got
laid off of my restaurant job in like
2010 um
i was making more money on unemployment
than i made at that job
so i was like wow what's the incentive
it's about to run out though
yeah i think they're gonna stop like
this month
what crazy oh don't worry they'll just
keep printing money dude
it'll be fine i hope so
i want people to no i'm not worried
right nothing could
affect that way people who hold assets
get to accumulate more wealth i know
well while they drive down the dollar
for everybody else that's dumb
yeah it's fun it's a time honor
tradition now when you were asking me
who they were giving the money to they
did actually mention
that the proceeds from the sales of
these cutouts will benefit the los
angeles dodgers foundation
so who does that benefit for advertising
more baseball i know
that'd be so sick i was looking at the
map the other day and it said dodger
stadium
currently closed and then
damn so i'm like oh they're actually
playing games still but they're close to
the public yeah they're
fanless they should at least have like
some sort of
like crowd cheering ambiance
like how weird playing silent games yeah
oh like almost like a laugh check but a
cheer track
i think some countries have that and
they're like it's kind of weird well
because like chargers games they have
that
because there's not enough chargers fans
so they amplify the sound
oh it's like cheering so they did that
pre-covered
dude the atlanta falcons did that a
couple years ago they were piping in
crowd noise to [ __ ] with
teams who came in so like if you're
trying to call signals at the line
and you've got too much crowd noise it
[ __ ] with you that's what home field
advantage is about but
atlanta falcons fans don't give a [ __ ]
about the exactly what it was that was
that's what it was like when we saw the
chargers versus screen bay
oh and chargers versus colts true but
there were
nobody's [ __ ] cheer for these guys
where's this noise going from hey baby
oh that's sad it's also not supposed to
happen either according to rules but
what's worse having a crowd that doesn't
cheer
or not having a crowd at all i think it
depends so i've been listening to
some fighters and they're just talking
about so they talk about three different
comparisons one in the american crowd
uh we cheer a lot but we're also a bunch
of [ __ ] idiots yup so we cheer the
wrong [ __ ]
and when there's something very
technical happening in a fight
people are done get up you [ __ ] [ __ ]
so
they're cheering the wrong way and it
pisses the fighters especially when we
get drunk
yes i start cheering at the replays i'm
like do you see that catch
so you so you say stupid [ __ ] and it
pisses the fighters off and then they're
they're trying to have a good fight but
the audience wants an exciting fight
do a cartwheel yes there's that kind of
stuff right and then so some of those
fighters are saying that when it's quiet
they actually really enjoy it but a lot
of them are saying their actual
favorite is in japan so in japan the
audience
are actually very well educated on
fighting so when there's something
that's like
like let's say passing the guard with
just like a jiu jitsu move something
that the americans would
boo everyone's like
like that like it's like because they
they view it as chess
so they view it as chess and then
they're like dammit this audience
gets gets what i'm doing versus we have
golf like a golf phone yeah yeah yeah i
like that
i mean dude we are very stupid people
we're [ __ ] stupid think about
true think about what we do to the poor
buckingham palace guys who are just
supposed to stop
they're like
you moving are you gonna move like we
are [ __ ] stupid i'm not touching you
i'm not touching you yeah
like i hate how there's like so many
stereotypes about americans but but
mostly i just hate that they're true
so true hey we like to party all right
it's universal
we like to party i mean especially now
with this whole pandemic too i'm like
damn it's embarrassing
we're so stupid i think i would prefer
an empty audience than an audience that
just stares at me and doesn't choose
one's personal rejection yeah
don't like you or else i mean right now
i can
say like oh it's because of corona no
one's here yeah
you know but then if someone does show
up and they just blank stare at you and
it's not a cultural thing
i'd be like what the [ __ ] that's a
loser's mindset joe
is it a loser's mindset yeah you gotta
be like no they will cheer
i'll make them cheer i'll make them it
blindsided me though
wait you got booed or what no no like
i'm i'm i'm
i'm an athlete you know and then i'm
performing and then i'm doing my thing
and i look up at the crowd and then
therefore it blindsided you
in your in your head yeah okay in my
performance
so i'm i'm like i'm like [ __ ] running
and i do the [ __ ] goal
go right [ __ ] what is this
i ran over the football line
it's touchdown dude yeah that is his
sport
maybe he's talking about football yeah
it's a football it's it's world football
so he's carrying the soccer ball
so i cross it and then and then when i
look up at the stage
no one cheers for me that's hard that's
hard that happened to me but in a
different way when i was a kid
i was a soccer game i'm kicking the ball
down the field i'm hearing everyone's
[ __ ] shouting and [ __ ] and i'm like
hell yeah i look at the goalie
and i [ __ ] kick it in and then i'm
like oh my god that was my goalie oh my
god
that's why i was tired i scored on my
own
100 true story that happened in an
episode of full house i didn't know if
people could actually be that dumb
hey we're all americans it can't it can
happen i was like seven
uh but you don't forget that [ __ ] at
least you were cute
i know i wasn't that cute i was too tall
oh yeah i was too tall on a little kid
should have been a goalie
awkward do you think it'd be really
awkward if we had a live audience for
this show
no i want to do that that'd be fun yeah
i think it'll be great no i mean like
if they don't laugh to your jokes oh
they're just like um
oh no they'll laugh see what is mine why
don't they just not laugh in your head
then i'll be sad no i'll be blindsided
i'll be like what
that was a good [ __ ] joke they
laughed what the oh they're just shy
that's what happened it's always their
fault you're like a really good stand-up
comic
like i love seeing that [ __ ] a show that
was a good [ __ ] joke oh that's the
craziest [ __ ]
that's a good [ __ ] joke right there
you have a sense of humor you guys are
rough
yeah it's so awkward it's so weird
i like planning you're blindsided though
like
okay and then i'll be blindsided and
then
i'm shocked you never had a
flabbergasted moment in your
imagination no plan for them
you can't plan right but then otherwise
you're it's not a blind side
it is i'm gonna walk down this hallway
and i'm gonna be surprised over there
i am surprised i make a shot and it's
like go
and then i look up and then but in your
mind i'll make this shot this way now
why didn't they say yay but you could
change them
in your head in my head yeah but that
it's not fun when it works out perfectly
i like about you though is that you're
flabbergasted surprised but
at the end the conclusions it's always
their fault they're either
obviously they don't know what's going
on like that's dope good for you man you
are that stand of comic
yes in my narcissistic projection
in my mind my real life you can't do
that in real life dude you know what
is weird though is in dreams when they
tell you some [ __ ] and i'm like that's
some real [ __ ]
like that's surreal [ __ ] like what like
uh i can't think of a good example right
but a couple of times i've had
epiphanies where like
the person told me like you're not meant
to know right now and i'm like
oh oh [ __ ] like this thing i've been
thinking about this whole time
and i'm like hey what happened and
they're like you're not meant to know
and i'm like i wake up from the dream
and i'm like
i'm not mentioning you never argue with
that person no i tried
oh they were i was like but tell me i
need it and they're like
some things are better left unsaid
that's true [ __ ] they just spit some
real [ __ ] at me
but it's really my mind saying that but
i don't how come when when you wake up
from a dream
it never sounds as beautiful like the
other night i'm going i had to wake her
up to go to bed because she's
falling asleep on the couch and she's
like she's like am i an avocado
i talk in my sleep she's like dead
serious about it too and i've learned
over the years because
when we first got together i'd be like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
right but if i do that then she's like
oh my god like are you serious like i
just said the most [ __ ] normal thing
ever and you're
asking me what am i talking about so
then i was like
yeah matter of fact you think you're
wrong yeah right so that's because she's
very intent on it so she's like
i'm an avocado and i'm like yeah
and then she's like how much i'm like i
don't know five like you're five
and she's like okay you just have to
answer her when she's
she gets up and then her eyes open yeah
she's fully
is this happened my whole
i really hate when people laugh at me
apparently you're
waking up and you don't even remember
anything i don't remember any of this
but when people recount it to me they're
like they start laughing
and they they're like yeah we still we
laugh because like it was ridiculous
but then you got really [ __ ] pissed
she [ __ ] hates you and i even yell at
them and gibberish i'm like
you know clowns are you you're in the
walls in the closet okay
antarctica she's like don't make fun of
me
so yeah it's almost like a party trick
because she falls asleep in people's
parties all the time
and then she does this [ __ ] and then
[ __ ] she kills the room
because people are like everyone's
laughing and then she kills the room
because she scolds them for laughing
you're just channeling your inner
crackhead that's all it is yeah
basically you both are hilarious when it
comes to sleeping because then you
you'll be sitting there oh yeah
like this he's he's gonna have some
alcohol in him yeah well he's sleeping
like
he's literally like sleeping like this
he does not like to admit that when he's
drunk
no and he does the same thing and he
still tries to have normal conversations
he's like
the astronauts know what i'm talking
about and it's like all right
you gotta go to bed anybody did it would
be astronauts now
i wanna record what happens when both of
you fall asleep because it feels like
you guys have a random conversation
astronauts and avocados we're two peas
in a pod dude
you